[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN:
Well, thank you.
It is great to be
with all of you today.
Luke, thanks for introducing
me and also just inviting
me here to be with all of you.
To those of you--
I've heard there are
people streaming right now.
That's what I look
like, but I can't
give a talk for 45 minutes
with myself behind me
the whole time.
So apparently when this
goes up on YouTube,
they'll integrate it.
And people there can watch
me and not just the slides.
But if you're
streaming, you're just
going to get the slides and
my voice from here on out.
So I'm a social neuroscientist.
I have been looking at
people's brains, mostly using
MRI scanners, for about 20 years
now, a little longer than 20
years.
And at some point
around 10, 12 years ago,
I started getting
invited to come
speak to different
business-related groups.
And actually, a
bunch of the talks
were at Oracle early on and
other leadership organizations.
And so it got me thinking
about, what on earth
does my work have to say
that's relevant to business,
to thinking about how
the social brain is
doing its thing at work.
And so part of what I
think about is how do we
promote well-being,
productivity, happiness--
all these things that you
want to see more of at work?
And to do this, you
basically need a good model,
a good theory of what motivates
and drives human beings.
And so I think that the
inherited wisdom we've had
for hundreds of years--
you can't really
do much better than Thomas
Hobbes, who summed it up
in a single sentence.
"Man has no other end,
in all his actions,
than his private self-interest."
So we get as much good stuff
as we can for as little
work, as little
pain as possible.
And if you want to see
evidence of this, one easy way
to see this is to go to a game
that economists developed,
I think, back in the late '80s--
maybe it was the early '90s.
No, it was earlier.
It was the '80s. --called
the prisoner's dilemma.
And I'm sure some of you are
familiar with the prisoner's
dilemma.
I won't describe all
the details of it.
The key things you
need to know is
that typically two
people are playing
with or against each other.
They never meet each
other, and they are never
going to meet each other.
They typically play
one round of the game,
so there's no concern
with reputation.
And the key thing about
the way you play the game
is that your outcomes
are interdependent.
So the way you play affects
both your outcomes and the other
person's.
And the same is true
for them as well.
And so there's two ways
you can play the game.
You can play the
game selfishly, where
you try to maximize
the amount of money
you'll take for yourself.
And it is definitively
going to come
at the expense of less
money for the other person.
And the other option is to play
in a more communal sort of way,
where you try to maximize
the amount of money
that you and the other person
are going to earn jointly.
But that will definitely
come at the expense of you
getting less money personally.
These are the two options.
And in line with
economists' predictions,
the vast majority of people
play this game selfishly.
They go and say, I'll take
the most money for myself,
thank you very much.
And so games like this give
rise to the view of human nature
as being something
like Homo economicus,
something like that,
where we're basically
rationally
self-interested creatures,
where we're
fundamentally selfish,
we try not to exert
too much effort,
we can be reasonably
rational in some contexts,
and we pursue wealth and other
material gains for ourselves.
And that's what's
been shown in hundreds
and hundreds of iterations
of this game, the prisoner's
dilemma.
But there's a
version of this game
that you are probably not
familiar with that I think
is an interesting contrast.
So actually, it's
the exact same game.
So in this version
of the game, you
have the exact same
rules described
to you word for word the same.
And you play the game
exactly the same way.
But at the start of the game
when they're introducing
the rules, instead of
describing or defining
the game one way or another,
in this particular version
of the game, they
say, today you're
going to be playing
the community game.
And then they explain
the exact same rules
as what is normally taking
place in the prisoner's dilemma.
And when you do
this, the percentage
of people who play selfishly
drops precipitously.
And suddenly now,
almost everybody-- well,
3/4 of people--
suddenly now play
communally and try
to do what's best for the group.
And so in addition to
suggesting that human beings are
exquisitely sensitive to context
and situational pressures
and so on, what it
also may suggest
is that we are more than
just Homo economicus.
We are also Homo socialis--
that we may have these
intrinsic social concerns
and that what we're
looking for is
when we're supposed to
demonstrate these motives
and when we're supposed to
demonstrate those motives
and that we have both of
these and we use both.
I'm not trying to suggest
we're not selfish creatures.
We are.
But we are not only
selfish creatures
is part of what I'll argue.
So for the time I
have with you, I'm
going to try to do three things.
The first thing I'm going to
try to do is present to you
some of the neuroscience
data that we've
collected in an
attempt to prove to you
that our ability and our
skills at being social
is not just another
program we learn like how
to play chess or algebra.
Those are things
that we can learn
because we have this great
prefrontal cortex that's
super flexible and can learn
any new rule-based kind of thing
if it's useful for
us to learn it.
But instead, what
I'm going to suggest
is that our social
operating system
is part of the basic
components of who
we are as mammals, that all
mammals actually share this
and we have plenty
of it as well.
If I convince you of
that-- hopefully I will--
I'll spend some
time, then, trying
to tell you some
things about why
paying more attention
to our social nature
is really important for thinking
about happiness, well-being,
and productivity
in the workplace.
And then I assume
I will have time
because I set a timer
for myself to make
sure I get to this last piece.
Because that's the piece I'm
actually most excited about.
That's about where
our work is going
and where it's now really
directly relevant to thinking
about neuroscience-- and social
neuroscience, specifically--
in the workplace and how we
can use it there in a way
that it, I think, really
hasn't been used in the past.
But let's start at
the beginning, trying
to convince you that some of
the social aspects of ourself
are really, really a
basic part of who we are.
So let's start with the
concept social pain.
So we came up with the
concept of social pain back
in the early 2000s.
And because we came up with
it, we got to define it.
And so our definition--
there's various ones
we've used-- but it's
the pain associated
with actual or potential threats
to one's social connections.
And if we want to
be extra wordy,
it can be actual or
potential threats
to one's actual or potential
or imagined social connections.
So it's a pretty
flexible concept.
But when most people
see this definition,
what you're likely to
think is, oh I get it.
So people are bothered when
they're socially rejected,
so you're using social pain.
But that's just a metaphor.
Social pain is
metaphorical language.
It's poetic license.
And so what I want to
take a few minutes to do
is to think about what it
would take to persuade you
that social pain is every bit
as much of a real kind of pain
as when you stub your toe
or when you have a headache,
that from the
brain's perspective
and from an evolutionary
perspective, social pain
is very much a
real kind of pain.
It just manifests in a
slightly different way.
But all physical pains
manifest in different ways.
So the first thing
that's worth noting
is that while this may be a
metaphor for social pain--
and in English, we use language
like "you hurt my feelings"
and "she broke my heart."
So we use the language
of physical pain
to talk about social pain.
And it turns out it's
not just in English.
There was a paper published
years ago-- not by my group--
showing that in languages all
around the world, including
lots of non-romance languages,
the language of social pain
is based in the language
of physical pain.
At least, I assume it is.
Every once in a while
now, when I get up here,
I realize I can't
translate most of these.
But I assume the authors
who wrote this paper could,
and someone would have made them
retract the paper by this point
if they were inaccurate
in their translations.
So we are neuroimaging folks.
We're neuroscientists.
And so our approach
is not to look
at how the language is
common around the world,
although I think that's
super interesting.
But instead, we
tend to put people
in these giant
coffin-like donuts
where you hear
really loud noises.
It's not a terribly pleasant
place to be-- unless you're me.
I tend to fall asleep in
scanners when people put me in.
It's a little bit like being
in the womb, or it's terrible.
It's one or the other
for most people.
And we bring folks in.
And this was back in 2001, 2002.
We brought folks
in, and we had them
play this silly little ball
tossing game called Cyberball.
And in Cyberball, you're
controlling this hand
at the bottom.
If you're the subject
in our scanner,
you're controlling this hand.
And you believe you're playing
with two other real people
over the internet who are also
laying in scanners right now.
Of course, we are
social psychologists,
so we lie to people
all the time about what
they're doing in the studies.
And after a few minutes,
the game changes.
And some of you
may now start to be
able to realize how
the game changes.
The other two people, who
are really just code--
they're not people at all--
they stop throwing the
ball to the real subject.
And this goes on
for a few minutes.
Subjects get out of the scanner,
and they're usually either kind
of depressed or angry.
But they definitely tend to
have a significant emotional
response to this.
And so what we
were interested in
is what was happening
in the brain
while people were being rejected
or excluded from the game
compared to the earlier period
when they had been included.
These are the brain regions
associated with the distress
of physical pain.
So the more bothered you are
by any painful experience
that you have, the
more activity you're
going to see in
these two regions.
And when we looked
in the brain at what
was different between
the people's responses
when they were being excluded
compared to when they were
included, these were
the only two regions
of the brain that were more
active during rejection
than when folks were included.
Moreover, when people
got out of the scanner,
we asked them to tell
us how painful it
was to be rejected
while they were
playing this very boring game.
And the more they
told us they felt
that it was a
painful experience,
the more these two regions
showed increasing responses.
And so this persuades
a fair number of people
that social pain is
a real kind of pain.
But if it doesn't persuade you,
perhaps the follow-up study
will.
It turns out that if
you give people Tylenol,
all these effects go away.
So the same pain killer that
you take for your headaches
actually works in some
sense for your heartaches,
for your sense of being
rejected or excluded.
It works for that as well.
Important caveat here--
do not try this at home.
Tylenol is super toxic.
500 people a year die
from Tylenol overdoses.
And so while there are
clinical trials going on
and we did this, this was done
in a very proper, appropriate
lab-based way.
Don't do this at home, OK?
There, I told you not to.
If you do, that's on you now.
All right, so we have this,
I think, very basic, inborn
sensitivity to social
rejection that manifests itself
in the form of pain.
And it turns out
it's not just humans.
All mammals show this
kind of response,
and they tend to show it in
the same regions of the brain.
So you can look at rats,
you can look at monkeys--
there are other animals that
have been looked at as well--
and they tend to show
this same response.
We have it because
for humans, who
are born incapable of
taking care of themselves
when they're infants, you
need a way to stay connected.
And this makes the
infant and the caregiver
feel connected and are
very sensitive to distress
in the other.
Especially the caregiver is very
sensitive to the social pain
distress calls
given by the infants
of pretty much any mammals.
And so the upshot of
this is that social pain
is one of the things that
motivates us to stay connected,
to stay together.
And that allows us to do all
sorts of extraordinary things
like build buildings
with air conditioning
and roofs and things like
that that, pretty much,
if you were on your own and
weren't feeling any motivation
to connect with other people,
we might never have developed
these sorts of things.
Now, on the flip
side of social pain,
we have social
pleasures, which are
nicer to think about and
talk about and so on.
And it turns out that the
same pretty primitive brain
system that we share with
reptiles and most other animals
that can walk, the ventral
striatum, the region
shown in fire here--
this is a region
that we've known
for years and years responds
when people in the scanner
win money, when they
get to eat something
that's delicious, when they look
at pictures of pretty people.
All those things
activate this system.
But it also turns out
we've known for a few years
now that being liked,
loved, respected,
or even just feeling
understood are all things that
activate this same system.
So this is a system
that seems to be just as
sensitive-- some
evidence suggests
it's more sensitive to social
rewards than these other kinds
of rewards that we
tend to think of when
we think of rewards in general.
All right, "It's better
to give than to receive."
You've all heard this
presumably at some point.
Usually it's
associated with someone
getting a pretty bad gift
around Christmas or Hanukkah.
Does anyone know who
first said "It's better
to give than to receive?"
I'll tell you-- your brain.
Your brain first said
this because all humans
are built with this wired in.
Remember, we started with
the prisoner's dilemma,
where you can decide to play
selfishly or for the group.
And if you have any strong
views that we are rationally
self-interest going for the
money kinds of creatures,
you might imagine that there'd
be social norms suggesting
that there are
times when we think
we're supposed to give money to
the group, to work communally.
You could say that
community condition was just
people being sensitive to
norms and being afraid of what
the experimenter would think.
But if that's the
case, you would still
expect that the brain's reward
system to respond most strongly
when people chose to play
the game in the way that
would, by definition,
maximize their own earnings.
But that is not what happens
in the prisoner's dilemma.
In the prisoner's dilemma,
you get the most activity
in the ventral striatum
when you play communally.
So this is a case--
this is a different
kind of social reward.
The first kind I told you about
is when people tell you they
like, love, respect you.
This kind of social reward
is when you do for others.
And it turns out
that we're built such
that doing for others is
also a rewarding, pleasurable
experience, one
that we don't always
have a very good theory of.
But it definitely is true.
Adam Grant, who's at the Wharton
School in Pennsylvania, UPenn--
he wrote a wonderful
book on the benefits
of being a giver at
work instead of a taker.
If you are going to buy one
book this year, well, buy mine.
But if you're going to buy
two, I would highly, highly
recommend his book.
And one of the things
he found in this book
is that if you go take folks
who are doing relatively
menial, thankless work, like
working a phone bank trying
to raise money for scholarships
for the university, where
everybody is hanging up
and trying to get off
the phone with you,
and you bring someone
in who won one of
their scholarships
that they're raising money
for who then tells some
of these phone bank folks about
how the work they're doing
actually tangibly
benefits someone,
the productivity of these
folks goes through the roof.
And when I say it
goes through the roof,
I don't mean that
day or the next day
where you would expect them to
be like, oh, that was so great.
That was fun that we heard
from that 20-year-old
telling us what this
award meant for them.
It's a month later that
they come back and measure.
And a month later,
the productivity
of the folks who got
this intervention
is dramatically higher.
And this has been
replicated several times
in different contexts, so
I think it's really legit.
So humans are sensitive to
social pain, social pleasure.
You would think that if these
are things that can really
move around our
well-being, we might
have a system in
our brain that helps
us navigate the social
world so that we
can maximize our
social pleasures
and minimize the social pains.
For some time, people
thought that it
was the basic analytical
system in the brain, which
is shown here in green--
loosely shown here in green.
These are systems
that are involved
in math and logical reasoning
and accounting and working
memory, holding things
temporarily in mind.
But it turns out
that there really
is a completely
separate network that's
involved in our social
thinking that doesn't really
overlap with the network for
analytical thinking at all.
And we've learned some
interesting things
about this network.
One of the things
we've learned is
that these two networks--
the social thinking
and analytical thinking
networks-- kind of operate
like a neural seesaw, where
activity in one going up
tends to be associated with
activity in the other going
down and vise versa.
They seem to trade
off of each other.
And we can think
immediately about how
that might be relevant
in the workplace, right?
I assume Google,
like most companies,
really prioritizes people being
highly analytically skilled
many, many hours of the day.
And the goal is to
just emphasize that
without necessarily detracting
from other capacities
that we might have.
But there's some
evidence to suggest
that if you're putting
the pedal to the metal
on the analytical side, that may
come at a real cost of actually
dampening down some
of our social skills
and our ability to
detect certain things
socially in others in
our social environment.
Another thing we've learned
is sort of a funny result,
and I'll show it
to you this way.
So let's say I brought
you into my scanner.
It's not my scanner.
It's UCLA's scanner.
I brought you in, and I told
you that what you're going to do
is lay in the scanner.
And you're going to
do math for a minute,
and then you're going to
lay there and rest and do
nothing for a minute, and then
math for a minute and rest.
And the math is super easy.
It's like 3 plus 4 type math.
And the rest is nothing.
And this time, even though
I'm a social psychologist,
I'm not lying to you.
This is exactly what
you do while you're
laying in the scanner.
And so we can go look at these
analytical parts of the brain,
and they will do just what
we would expect them to do.
They'll do something like this.
This is idealized, but
something like this.
When you're doing math, the
analytical parts light up.
And when you're
resting, they quiet down
because you don't need
them to rest and do nothing
while you're laying
in the scanner.
Now, we can look at
the same exact task
and what's happening
in the social brain,
in the social thinking network.
Well, what we would
expect to see is this--
not much at all.
Because you don't need your
social brain to do math.
In fact, if you activate your
social brain while you're
doing math, it interferes.
And you don't need your
social brain during rest.
So that's what
we'd expect to see.
But what you
actually see is this.
So the social brain comes on
incredibly reliably any time
there is a break in the action.
And it comes on within a
few hundred milliseconds
of finishing any sort of
cognitive, goal-directed task.
So there are folks who have done
things with depth electrodes.
They put them right in
the right positions,
and they can tell within
300 milliseconds--
it's actually a guy
at Stanford nearby--
that within 300 milliseconds,
the social brain
pops back on whenever there's
a break in the action.
And so we can ask ourselves,
well, why would that happen?
And while I'm not going to
spend lots of time in my lecture
today going over
why that happens,
what I can tell you is that the
summary result from our studies
is that to the extent that
you spontaneously activate
this network in short
periods of downtime
in between more significant
events in your life,
if the next thing you have to
do involves social thinking,
you're better prepared for it.
You actually perform
better on social tasks
where you have to
think about what's
going on in the minds of
other folks to the extent
that this network has
spontaneously activated itself.
And what that suggests is
that evolution has essentially
made a bet that the
best thing to do
with our spare
cycles in our brain
as we have downtime is to get
ready for thinking socially,
that that is really
evolutionarily significant.
Because this is pretty much the
only thing in the brain that
has this sort of pattern, where
every time there's a break
and we can reset, it resets
towards the social domain.
We actually have a lot of
data that speaks to that now.
And so in essence,
what that does for us--
and I think this is
really, really important--
is that when we look
out into the world,
we could see all of this
just as physical objects
in physical motion.
We could describe it all in
terms of physics and mechanics
and so on.
But most people-- the
vast majority of people--
when they look at
this, what they see
has psychological meaning.
They see people having thoughts,
feelings, interactions,
intentions.
And this tendency to
turn on this network
as we walk into
each new experience
is something that
prepares us to see
the world in a
psychological fashion
rather than in a physics-based,
mechanical fashion.
So that's a very short course
on some of the evidence that
suggests that we really do
have some basic social features
to us and that we are not
purely self-interested.
We are not just Homo economicus.
We are that but not just that.
Of course, I could have
skipped those 20 minutes
and just showed you the quote
from Albert Einstein where
he says, "Man owes his
strength in the struggle
for existence to the fact
that he is a social animal."
But, you know, then I would
have no job being here at all.
I could've just
showed you that slide.
So I'm going to spend a
few minutes telling you now
about how some of these things
relate to business directly,
and then I'm going to turn
to what we're doing now
with a different kind
of neuroscience that's
more work-relevant.
And I'm pretty excited
to get to that.
OK, so in any workplace,
in any business,
you're off trying to hire folks.
And it's been a long
time, now, that we've
understood that the
goal of hiring folks
is to accrue the most talent.
So any HR department
is out there
trying to find the individuals
who are A-plus people.
And the A-plus
people are the people
with the highest IQs, the
most training and experience,
who went to the best schools.
And norms about these
things change over time,
but that's roughly
speaking describing
what's happened over the
last couple of decades
in terms of how we
try to acquire people.
And the goal is to
make sure, then,
that your company has
the most human capital.
It's almost like a sort
of role-playing game
where you're trying
to get people
with the most intellectual and
academic skills for performing
the feats they will
need to do at work.
Some economists looked
at this and discovered
that if you want to
see the relationship
between human capital and
the company's bottom line,
the vast majority
of that relationship
is actually explained by the
links between the individuals
in the company.
And so here what
we're talking about
is not human capital but social
capital, the extent to which
a company makes the boundaries
between people and sections
of the company permeable so
that they can connect easily
with each other.
And what's critical
about this is
you've got this A-plus person
down here with some special set
of skills.
And if they're
siloed and they don't
feel really connected
to other folks,
well, that person
up there is never
going to benefit from their
skills when they could
and vise versa.
This person is not going
to easily seek them out
because they don't have an easy
path to get access to them.
So it's important to build this
kind of social capital purely
for economic reasons
at companies.
Here's another version
of something similar.
So this is a phone bank
company, I think, in Germany.
And the company Humanyze, who
does the badge testing where
it tracks your every
movement throughout the day--
they did a study
with this company.
And the way the company was
working when they showed up
is that there'd be five or six
people in a phone bank that
were in a pod together.
And they would get their
15 minute breaks staggered,
so they all took their
breaks at different times.
And Humanyze came in and said,
hey, why don't you give them
their breaks together?
Because if you give them
their breaks together,
they'll actually be
more socially connected
to one another and actually
feel like they're on a team.
Now, this seems like a
really small difference.
But it turned out
that this difference
had really significant
effects on the extent
to which people at the
company felt cohesive
with the other people
they worked with,
the productivity they had,
the stress levels they had.
So these simple
changes where they're
being sensitive to enhancing
the social dynamics of the group
had really substantial effects.
And they've done other
studies like this as well
and tend to see something.
If nobody is focusing on the
social aspects of a company,
that becomes low-hanging fruit.
Because nobody's actually gone
after the low-hanging fruit
before.
And this is, I think,
that sort of thing.
We can think about
performance feedback.
Everybody gets performance
feedback at most companies.
There's a few companies
that have done away with it.
It's hard to do away with it.
You want your employees
to get feedback,
but nobody likes getting
performance feedback.
And so for me, one of
the things I always
think about when I think
about performance feedback
is that for the person
giving the feedback,
they're just giving
constructive advice
for how you can go be more
efficient and effective.
And for the person
receiving the feedback,
it's like somebody's
punching you in the face--
typically, unless you're
the golden child of whatever
company you're working at.
And so we have a way
of understanding that.
So we've talked
about social pain,
and the idea is that
if we think of this
as a genuinely painful
event for people
to be told information that
may make you feel less valued
and worthy at the company
that you're working at,
then it's weird to think
that those folks should
be able to just go back
to work and be effective.
We wouldn't expect
someone to break their leg
and then go back to work.
We'd say, go get
that taken care of
and come back to work when
it's all in a cast and feeling
better.
There's work that shows
that after people have been
rejected, their IQs
go down significantly
and their performance
on standardized tests
like the GREs plummet--
68% if you've just been accepted
and made to feel good, 39%
if you've just been rejected.
So after you've
just been rejected,
don't go take the GREs.
You will not do well.
It's not a good solution.
Eat some ice cream.
We can think more
directly about happiness
and how to promote that.
We know, of course, that two
of the major factors that drive
happiness are money and health.
So let's start with health.
So we all know smoking's
bad for you, right?
In California, almost
nobody ever smokes anymore.
But in most of the world,
lots of people still smoke.
You can look at the
morbidity statistics
for your likelihood
of essentially dying
from different
kinds of behaviors,
from not being physically
active, being obese,
having pneumonia.
And smoking's like the
worst one from behaviors
that you can
personally engage in.
Smoking's really, really bad.
And that's one of the
reasons we spend about a
half billion dollars a
year in the United States
to stop people from smoking and
to get people to stop smoking
once they have started.
But what I haven't
shown you here,
which is the most interesting
part of the chart,
is that it actually turns
out that not cultivating
a meaningful social
group is actually
more dangerous to your
health than smoking
15 cigarettes a day.
So while health is super
important for your well-being,
it turns out that being
socially connected
is also super important
for your well-being.
We know people
value being wealthy.
We know people value
material wealth.
The percentage of
people who value it
has gone up and up
in the United States.
And I value it too, so I'm not
really throwing stones at all.
But what I will say is that this
seems largely to be a mistake.
Because as wealth rises,
happiness typically
doesn't change at all.
And you can cut the data
a million different ways.
Unless you're moving
people from genuine poverty
to out of poverty--
then every dollar really
does change happiness
and well-being.
But once you hit a
certain threshold,
you get very diminishing
returns for increasing money.
So what makes people happier?
Well, the people who
report being very happy
are the people who spend lots
of time with friends and family.
Some economists looked
at this using money
as a sort of comparison point.
And they said, OK, how much does
spending an extra hour a week
with someone you really like,
going to get coffee with them
or something like that--
how much does that
increase your happiness?
And they put it
in terms of money.
They said, how much
money would you
have to make extra
in a given year
in order to get the same
amount of happiness you
get from spending an hour
a week with a good friend?
It turns out it's a
giant amount of money.
You have to make an
extra $100,000 a year
to get the same increase
in your happiness
as spending an hour
with someone you like.
You get to pick the
person you're talking
about here, someone you like.
Which of these is
more fun, working
to make an extra hundred grand
or spending time with a friend?
And as we do this, we
have less time to do this.
These are the
choices we all make.
We move cross-country
for job opportunities
and leave our social
networks behind.
We can think about this within
the workplace specifically,
not just having friends in life
but having friends at work.
It turns out that
while people who
love the company
they work at often
say it's because they love the
interesting and challenging
work they do there,
they also often say
their number one reason for
loving the company they work at
is the co-workers that
they get to work with.
And people who say, I have
a best friend at work--
people who answer yes to this--
the divisions of companies
they work in tend to have
customers who are happier,
they're more productive, and
they show greater profit.
So the upshot of this-- and then
I'm going to turn to my last
piece--
is that in the
workplace, we tend
to think that this
is the primary way
to incentivize people.
When you look at all the
incentive structures,
they almost always
either come down
to current or future promised
money in one form or another.
Health plans are
just money that are
being spent for you in a
certain other material way.
And the point is that
we have some needs
that money are really,
really good at covering.
So if you go to
Maslow's hierarchy--
and this is a simplified
form with physical, social,
and meaning needs--
physical needs are pretty
well handled with money.
But the other two aren't at all.
And so again, these
become low-hanging fruit.
If nobody is
incentivizing anyone
with these other
approaches, then they
become a really
effective way for you
to make that kind of
difference in whatever group
you're working in.
OK, so last chunk of what
I'm going to talk about
is what I think one of the
big parts of the future
of social neuroscience
is, and it's
going to have a big
connection to the workplace
and not just be in the ivory
tower where I tend to work.
This kind of work
involves getting away
from giant, heavy MRI
scanners and getting
to lightweight, portable,
mobile neuroimaging technologies
like functional near-infrared
spectroscopy, or fNIRS.
MRIs depend on differences
in the magnetic properties
of oxygenated and
deoxygenated hemoglobin.
fNIRS is kind of
the same, except it
depends on the light
absorption properties that
differ between those
two types of blood.
It's basically just the same
thing as the pulse oximeter
you wear on your finger
when you go to the doctors,
except it's all over your brain.
And it's super
portable and mobile.
So you can put--
you're basically putting
a very small computer
and a sizable battery in a
backpack, which you can either
wear or put on the table
behind the subject.
It doesn't have to
actually be on your back.
But it allows you to
be flexible in where
you do your research
and the kind of research
that you can now do
that you could never
do with an MRI scanner.
And it has downsides as well.
There's no question.
It doesn't have the same
spatial resolution as MRI.
And currently, it doesn't
penetrate very deep
into the brain.
So it gets you the
cortical surface.
But I think in the next
five to seven years,
that's probably going to
change a fair bit as well.
So the first thing we did
when we decided to test out
this equipment was
we wanted to go
replicate something we had done
in our lab over and over again.
So there's this paradigm
that Emily Falk,
one of my former
graduate students,
and I developed, where we try
to persuade people while they're
laying in the scanner.
And then we ask them
later and track them
in various ways using wrist
trackers and other things
to see how much they've actually
changed their behavior in line
with whatever we were
trying to persuade them of--
to use sunscreen
more, to stop smoking,
to get more physical
exercise, to sleep more.
We do lots of public health
types of things like that.
And it turns out that
when you see activity
in this medial prefrontal
region here that's
shown in yellow there--
when that goes up when people
are seeing the messages,
people tend to then
change their behavior
in message-consistent ways.
We think this has
something to do
with basically adopting
and integrating
the message into your identity.
Because this is a
region that's very much
associated with
self-processes and valuation.
So we think-- but we
don't know for sure--
that that seems to be part
of what's going on there.
On the flip side, when people
are resistant to a persuasive
message and they're internally
counter-arguing saying,
this is stupid because--
you see more activity in the
right dorsolateral prefrontal
cortex, and you'll see less
behavior change over time.
So we did the same thing in
our first study with fNIRS,
and we basically found
the exact same result.
We were actually pretty
shocked that we found this.
We thought maybe we'd get
a little bit of something,
but there it is.
So this is showing--
to us, at least--
that we can do something
analogous with fNIRS
that we've been doing for
years and years with fMRI
and we had a lot
of confidence in.
But fNIRS has the ability
to do so much more
than just replicate
what we've been
able to do while
people are laying
on their back in the scanner.
And this often
involves an approach
called neural synchrony.
There's other names
for it as well,
but I call it neural synchrony.
And the basic idea is you
go to the same spot in two
different people's brains as
they're experiencing something,
and you look at how the activity
there fluctuates over time.
And to the extent that two
people in the same spot
in their brains are watching a
video or having a conversation
and they're fluctuations
are fluctuating together,
that's neural synchrony.
And if they're doing
random different things,
there is no synchrony
in that case.
And it turns out-- and I'll
show you data to back this up
in a minute--
that what this really
tends to get at
is whether two people
aren't literally just
being exposed to the same
thing but are sharing
the same experience of it.
They're experiencing
it and having
the same kind of
understanding and perspective
on what's going on.
But first, I want
to show you what
neural synchrony looks like.
So these are the
results of two people--
these are their brains--
watching a fighter pilot video.
They didn't watch it together.
They're just time-locked
to be shown together.
And let's see, to orient
you, the more red and orange
you can see on the
color bar over there,
the more activity
that's occurring
in that part of the brain.
And the more green and
blue, the less activity.
And so I think you'll be
able to hear the sound.
We'll just watch this.
It's a 20-second video,
but hopefully you
can see the synchrony
occurring with your own eyes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[JET ENGINE]
- And speed's now
coming up for 80 knots.
Positioning for the overbank,
waiting for the lead.
There goes the lead and
overbanking 5G over the top.
Throttle's back, so we
descend back into [INAUDIBLE]..
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN:
OK, so hopefully you
could sort of see it.
If not, this is each
of the two brains
at different points in time.
And you can see that the
brains are more like each other
than they are their own brain
at other points in time.
Now, here's the same video shown
again, this time without sound.
But this time, this
person on the right
is internally doing math.
So their eyes are on the video.
If you're looking
at them, you can't
tell that they're experiencing
it any differently
than this person.
But as soon as you see
their brains, it's obvious.
They are not experiencing
the same thing right now.
They are not responding
at all the same way
to what they're taking in.
And so this is really,
really cool-- at least,
I think it's really
cool-- that we
can tell this without
asking people,
how distracted were you?
Imagine at a
conference room meeting
and you're going to ask
everyone, so how distracted
were you during the meeting?
Nobody's going to
say, I was distracted.
They're all going to say,
oh, I was totally present.
And man, I'm having great
ideas after that meeting.
But we all know that
we've been that person,
and there's other people who
are being that person right now.
Some of you have no idea what
I'm talking about right now
because you're being that person
right now, and that's fine.
I have no problem with that.
Because if I was
in the audience,
I might be that person.
But I think that's a
really interesting thing,
to be able to detect that, I
think, in a pretty robust way.
So let me tell you
about something
that we've done
with this where we
can show it's really about
people sharing perspective.
So we take the equipment.
We put it in our
carry-on luggage.
This is Google Earth, so thank
you, Google, for making this.
This impresses people at
every other talk I give,
but I assume it would be
like, ugh, that again, here.
So we go halfway around
the world to Amman, Jordan.
And for the last
three summers, we've
set up pop-up mobile
neuroscience labs,
ran the first ever
social neuroscience
studies run anywhere in
the country or the region.
And what we were doing
in this particular study
that I'm going to
tell you about is
we found participants
over there who
were either pro-choice
or pro-life with respect
to abortion.
Now, there is an important
debate over there
that's pro-life, pro-choice.
It's not the same as our debate.
There's a general belief
that abortion is wrong.
But there is a debate
over whether or not
there should be an exception
in the case of rape.
So that's what this
particular debate is about,
and there's lots of
people on both sides.
It's about a 50/50 split, which
is what we were looking for.
And then we had videos made
of local individuals arguing
basically for the pro-choice
side or the pro-life side.
So we have videos,
native-language videos,
where people are arguing for
these two different sides.
And both groups saw both
videos while wearing fNIRS.
So then I'll take you
through what we looked at
and how this works.
So both groups watched
this pro-choice video.
So let's say we pull
out one of the people
from the pro-choice side.
So conceptually,
they're down here now.
Pretend they're not
up there anymore.
And so what we can
do is we can look
at the extent to which
this individual is showing
a synchronous response
with the average of all
the pro-choice folks up there.
And you can do this
iteratively, so then you
pull out a different subject
and put this one back.
And you do it for
everyone so that you
see how each person
is correlated
with the rest of the group
in the pro-choice group.
And when you do
this, what you see
is that there's
lots of synchrony.
So red on the scale
is up at the high end,
and then yellow is also
pretty high as well.
So we see lots of
synchrony there.
But when we do the
same thing where
we take someone who's pro-choice
and see how their brain
responses correlate with
the folks who are pro-life,
it's basically zero correlations
throughout the brain,
throughout the frontal
cortex where we were looking.
So they're seeing
the exact same video.
The same photons are
hitting their eyes.
The same sound waves
are hitting their ears.
But they experience it like
them and not like them,
and that's what's
coming out here.
And we can reverse it.
So now you pull someone out
from the pro-life group,
and they'll show synchrony
with the pro-life group
but not with the pro-choice
group-- just for complete sake.
And so once we started
getting results like this,
we started thinking
that there were
a wide range of applications.
And so one of the other people
in my department prodded me,
and so we went and
started a company
so that we could do
this in other places
where we wouldn't ordinarily
study this inside UCLA.
And so the idea
here is that as long
as we have two different kinds
of reference groups getting
at a particular kind
of way of experiencing
a piece of the world, we
can now basically figure out
what a new case is actually
seeing and experiencing
when they're looking at
something because we can look
at the extent to which they look
like more of a match for one
group or another.
And this lets us basically
and broadly speaking
study the science
of compatibility.
And it's in a very broad
kind of definition.
And so the idea here is if
you experience something
in similar ways as
another person or group,
then you'll show greater
synchrony with that person
or group under the proper
stimulus conditions.
So the pro-choice person
watching a pro-choice video--
not watching the Super Bowl, but
watching the pro-choice video--
then they're experiencing
something in the same way
or similar way to those folks.
And so then you can
see that sort of thing.
So imagine instead
of looking at this,
we were trying to figure
out who in a company
is experiencing
burnout right now.
Some people in
this room right now
are feeling burned out working.
It's a fact of the matter.
There's a decent
percentage of people
that are feeling burned
out, and it's a big problem.
People who are burned out leave.
Before they leave, their
productivity goes way down.
Burnout is contagious.
It's something that anyone
running a company or somewhere
up in management really,
really wants to avoid.
But you can't go
to your employees
and say, tell me, on a scale
from 1 to 10, how burned out
are you feeling?
Because people are typically
not going to tell you.
That's not one of
those things we
reveal in interviews and
performance reviews and things
like that.
But we could do the
same kind of thing
we did with the
pro-choice, pro-life.
But now, instead of looking
at pro-choice, pro-life,
we're looking at videos
of CEOs and executives
talking about feeling really
engaged or feeling burned out.
And then we have people
that have already
told us that they are feeling
engaged or burned out,
and we can see how they respond
when they watch these videos
and look at how that relates
to individuals in this way.
So to get at this-- it's hard
to get a bunch of executives
and CEOs in a room.
They don't like to all
show up at the same time,
so we went to them.
A few months ago, we went
to this event, Summit LA.
It's an ideas fest for
basically really wealthy CEOs
and executives.
I could never afford
to go to this event
unless I was invited,
which I was, thankfully.
And so once we were there,
people say yes to everything.
And so we were super
excited that a bunch
of CEOs and executives were
happy to come in and get
their brains scanned together.
This is literally the first
time four people have ever
been scanned while
having a conversation.
That's never
happened in any form.
So we thought that was
pretty cool in and of itself.
And they did interesting
things while they
were having conversations.
I'm not going to tell you
about that data today.
But another thing they
did is at one point--
there's a TV here--
they all turned and
looked at the TV,
and they watched
videos like these.
So they saw some people
talking about how
engaged and excited they
are at work, like this guy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- What's really exciting
to me personally
is the ability to make an impact
for millions if not billions
of people, having a commercially
successful product that
is driven by technology
but ultimately making
the human experience better.
We get a lot of messages
saying, thank you,
Ivy-- which is our hotel
concierge that we created.
By texting you, I
was able to get it
in two minutes at my door
and that really, you're
a lifesaver.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: So
you've got people like that.
And then you've also
got-- and to be fair,
he talked about both
the good and bad side.
And this next guy talked
about the good and bad side.
So it's not like this next
guy is super burned out.
We asked everyone to talk
about both aspects of their job
at different times.
This is someone talking
about feeling stressed out
about being a CEO.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You know, it's a very
stressful environment.
It's sort of
high-risk, high-reward.
You've got a lot riding
on pulling it off,
and that falls on the
CEO and on management.
And you've got your
investors relying on you.
You've got your employees who--
that's their job, and they're
feeding their families,
and they're living.
And so a lot of times, it
gets very close to the flame.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: OK, so
imagine that you're either
feeling super jazzed
about the work
you're doing-- you're
right where you should be--
or you're feeling burned out.
You're probably going
to experience these two
kinds of videos
differently based
on what's going on with
you in your life right now.
And so that's what
we wanted to look at.
So basically, everything
I'm going to show you
is from this same
medial prefrontal spot
that I've shown you in some of
the previous studies before.
It seems to be
associated with identity
and integrating things and
identifying with something
that you're taking in.
And so what we see is that when
people are watching the what
do you love about what you do
types of videos, what we see
is that the engaged
CEOs and executives--
they show a fair amount of
synchrony with one another
in that condition.
But the folks who are
feeling burned out
don't really show
any synchrony when
they're watching these
folks talk about how excited
and engaged they are.
When you see the folks talking
about being stressed and burned
out, now instead,
you see the burned
out folks who are sort
of stressed and feeling
the pressure-- these folks are
showing more synchrony with one
another than the
executives who are engaged
and thriving and so on.
So putting that together,
what you essentially
see is that the engaged
CEOs show a lot more
synchrony for the engaged
videos, and the folks who
are feeling more burned out show
more synchrony with the burnout
videos, the stress videos.
And we were actually,
using very simple machine
learning classification,
able to classify about 85%
of the folks who were feeling
burned out as being burned out
based on their brain data.
And so I think that's
a promising thing
because doing this, you don't
actually have to go ask folks.
We knew because we were
running that kind of study.
But in the future,
it could be used
in an application where you
don't know in advance who's
feeling one way or the other.
I'll just mention a couple of
the other applications of this
before I stop.
Dana Landis isn't here, right?
Is that right?
No, OK.
So Dana Landis is at
Google, but she's also
on our advisory board.
And so we've talked with her
about working towards solutions
for the diversity pipeline.
I know you guys have it in tech.
We have it in academia.
It's a genuine,
real issue that's
really, really hard to solve.
And one of the things
that we've talked
about is that you can go to
folks who aren't necessarily
getting exposed to
the best training
and they're not getting it
in an environment-- say,
in an inner-city school
environment, elementary school,
middle school, and so on, where
not only are you not getting
it, but there's not a lot
of emphasis in the family
or among friends
to really cultivate
an attitude towards what
I should spend my time
and energy on is learning how
to do algebra or something
like that.
It's just not
necessarily especially
valued, for understandable
reasons, in that context.
But if you can go
in and actually look
at who shows brain
responses when
they look at certain
mathematical or other types
of STEM concepts that even
look a bit more like folks who
have excelled in that
region, could you
identify aptitude in folks
who aren't going to show it
on traditional tests.
And there's some reasons
to think that you actually
can do this.
And so this is something
where if you could identify
those folks when
they're young, you
could bring them over
summers to summer institutes
where they get some of the kinds
of exposure and norm setting
that would lead people to
get to a place like Google
where they probably
wouldn't otherwise.
And probably the idea that
I'm most excited about
is that if we can get data
from the other work we're
doing on what thriving,
engaged brains look
like in a bunch of
different careers,
then you could
develop what we call
the neural guidance counselor,
where you could take
a 17-year-old who has no idea
what to do with their life--
and if you go to a regular
guidance counselor,
you're not going to get
any better idea of what
to do with your life.
I don't know that anyone's
ever had a good experience
with a guidance counselor.
They're either
neutral or creepy.
Like, those are the two options.
But what if you could
basically go find out,
OK, well, these are the things
where you, as a 17-year-old,
you look at certain things in
a way that's at least a bit
similar to people in
certain professions
who are both productive,
successful, and really happy
doing that job?
There's lots of other things
to think about in terms
of team construction.
So we had these
groups at Summit,
and they were having
conversations with each other.
And there's lots of
interesting dynamics,
like we varied the gender
composition of the groups
across the sessions.
And we don't have that
data analyzed yet,
but we're really,
really interested to see
how synchrony
profiles change when
it's zero women, one woman,
two women, three women, so on.
That's going to be
really interesting.
Also, some of these people are
the same people who told us
they were feeling burned out.
It turns out the people who
are feeling burned out also
reported being the least
interested and engaged
in what anyone else
had to say when
they were at these sessions.
So here's a way in which the
burnout feature is actually
having a genuine impact on the
way they interact with others.
And when the folks who
were feeling burned out
was asked who was the most
interesting, engaging person
at the table, they were
much more likely than anyone
else to say, me.
Most other people pointed to
someone else at the table--
I mean, in writing--
and said, oh, that person
was really interesting.
But the folks who were
feeling burned out-- they
said, I guess I was the
only interesting person
at the table.
Last thing is that there's
the obvious application
that this actually
directly applies
to regular old matchmaking.
And we've thought
about this a fair bit,
but we think that this gets
at a kind of compatibility
where when you use
Tinder or whatever else,
there's no measurement of
compatibility on match.com
or eharmony, who
even used to pretend
that they did compatibility.
It turns out it wasn't.
There's interesting
stories about that
that I won't go into.
But you can actually
measure compatibility
in a meaningful sort of way.
You want to find people--
the person that you want to
find and spend your life with
is probably going
to be someone that
actually in meaningful ways
sees the world similarly
to the way you see it-- not
visually, but conceptually.
And this is a way
to get at that.
And there is data that suggests
that this, in fact, can predict
who will become friends.
And there's no reason to
think it couldn't predict
who would become friends
that are more than friends
if you take into account
attraction and things
like that.
So I think that's a really
interesting feature of this
as well.
So I know that at this
point, I have gone long.
And so I will stop
there and say thank you.
And I'm happy to take any
questions if there are any.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is there any sense
of what types of companies
increase social interactions?
What are the variables
that are relevant?
One of the ones that
we talk about often
is the open workspace
environment.
There's a big study that
came out about it recently.
Are there other
things like that that
are useful when it comes to
increasing social interaction
in a good way?
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: Yeah, sure.
And I've given
talks for companies
about creating agile workspaces
where nobody has their own desk
or anything like that.
It kind of seems like a disaster
to do that for lots of reasons.
I think anyone who works
in one of those spaces
knows you get a roomful of
people wearing headphones.
But people also
feel a bit better
if they have some
space ownership.
It turns out a lot
of the motivation
for making those kinds of
spaces is that the company can
lease a lot less space.
Because when you're not
there, somebody else
can sit at the same desk, right?
Now, there is
evidence that suggests
that putting people in
proximity to each other
is really important.
So Humanyze-- who did the
thing with the water cooler,
15-minute breaks, and so on--
one of the other studies
they did is they looked at--
I think this was with
Deutsche Bank or some bank.
It may not be Deutsche Bank.
I may just have that
on the brain lately.
But they had different banks
where in some of the banks,
everyone who worked in a certain
division was on the same floor.
And in some companies,
they were just
on slightly different
floors, like one floor
apart with a stairwell
internal to it connecting them.
And there were
dramatic differences.
They managed to convince
them to switch one of these
to one of these, and the
productivity went way up.
And that seems to
be due to the fact
that now you've created a better
case for social permeability
so that people can connect
more easily and so on.
I think the other thing is that
we tend to just not think about
it very much.
And so it's easy to do.
I run a lab.
It's easy for me to forget that,
in some sense, part of my job
is providing for and creating
the right social atmosphere.
We think, well, I provide
my students with resources.
And I try to give them good
advice and wisdom and so on.
But this is also
where they're living
part of their social
life for several years.
We spend so many hours at work.
That has to have some
of the same features
that we look for
outside of work.
And I think that
companies sort of
think, well, I
don't want to spend
extra money on those things.
But it turns out you're not
because it reduces burnout.
It reduces-- so it's a
good play for the company,
but it's also really good for
the people who work there.
AUDIENCE: fNIRS--
yeah, so I'm just
thinking whether it could be
useful for personal, emotional
development.
How much does it cost, and
have you thought about that?
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: Sure.
OK, so there is a couple
of answers to this.
One is there's a lot of
fly-by-night equipment
out on the market right now,
and the vast majority of it
is junk.
So there's a bunch of
portable EEG things
where you get a single lead
that doesn't actually connect
the right way to the scalp.
You're supposed to use
certain kinds of leads
that those don't because
they're messy and expensive.
And so there's a lot
of stuff out there
that's junk that
people are using that--
I'm sure there's some
signal, but it's also
a signal swamped by noise.
fNIRS, like anything, has
some signal, some noise.
But I've been convinced
that the signal
is meaningful at this
point, although we're still
testing those things.
In terms of using
them for personal use,
I do think that that is a
plausible longer time horizon
scenario.
Right now they are a
bit clunky to set up.
You need a technician
there to set it up.
I don't know that
you could effectively
set up your own right now.
But we are working with hardware
companies about engineering
plans for how to make this
more consumer-friendly
at some point down the road.
So I think maybe in five years
we might be looking at that.
If you wanted to buy
one for yourself,
the lowest-end one
that I would think
is really worth using is
probably about $100,000.
There's toy ones that
you can get for $50,000,
but I really do think they
are toys and very, very
limited in what they can do.
$100,000 would basically
get you with pretty good
signal your prefrontal
cortex, and then it
doubles and triples
and so on from there.
And then in terms of the
other part of the question,
could you use it for personal
emotional development,
it would take something
really rigorous, I think,
set up by some kind of
company to make that work.
I don't think you could just sit
there and stare at your signal
and say, OK, I'm going to
work these parts in my brain,
and have that be
terribly meaningful.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: Yeah,
so we actually right now
are starting our collaboration
with a clinical psychologist
at UCLA, Michelle
Craske, where we're
going to have both the therapist
and the client wear fNIRS
during--
they do, like, 12 sessions,
12 weeks of sessions.
And so they're going
to do it in week 1,
I think, week 3, 6, 9, and 12.
And so we're very
interested in how
the dynamics both
within the individuals
and across the individuals
change over time
and how that predicts
who feels like they've
gotten the most out of it
and also who sticks with it.
Because most people
actually drop out
before they get to
what therapists say
should be the natural
stopping point.
AUDIENCE: I also have
a question about fNIRS.
So the first thing
that popped in my head
when you mentioned that it
could be used to measure burnout
when people don't actually
actively report it
is something like
"Black Mirror."
Not to bias you,
but I was wondering,
what do you see as
practically a way
to get people to get
their burnout measured
or something similar to that?
And what are the
ethical implications
of being able to do that?
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: Right,
so that's a good question.
We get the burnout, the "Black
Mirror" comment very regularly.
We actually, at
some point, thought
about naming the
company something that
would be an inside joke
about "Black Mirror",
like something from one
of the episodes just
to be really like, yep,
that's where we live.
And I think that
really depends on how
a company wants to
pitch what they're
doing to their employees.
So if finding out
folks are burned out
is then used in some
threatening way,
then that's not really
good for anyone.
But if it's used in a way
to direct more resources
and to help folks who are
vulnerable for leaving
the company or who might
benefit from certain types
of interventions, then
that's something that I think
is probably more positive.
But I totally agree
that there's some uses
of what we're doing, like
the neural guidance counselor
thing--
that's a pure benefit for
anyone who goes and does it.
If you're 17 and you go
and do this, you get told,
you're a 90% match with this
and a 30% match with that
and do with that what you want.
But you might not have
known these things.
A lot of us grow
up thinking, well,
I should do what my parents
did, or something like that.
Or we get into a random
internship after college
and suddenly, that's our
career 20 years later.
This is a way to sort
of try out things
that you could never
go try out on your own.
So I think that there's a range
of different applications.
And some of them, I think that
folks who want to use this
will have to think about,
well, what are the benefits
that a person gets?
And there are lots of
potential benefits.
So you could get
information yourself
that relates not
necessarily just to burnout.
If you're feeling burned
out, you probably know that.
But there's a lot
of other things
about the extent to which you
show certain kinds of skills
and aptitudes and so on.
People love things
like the Myers-Briggs,
even though it's complete junk.
It doesn't actually tell
you anything meaningfully.
Any psychometrician will say,
don't ever, ever use that.
But people are really,
really interested
because they want to get this
kind of standardized feedback.
And I think that is
one of the things
that this could be used to do.
We haven't done
that specifically,
but I think it could be used
in some of those domains.
And it could be
used to see if you
qualify to get certain kinds
of trainings or promotions
or whatever.
So you could have
your brain scan-- so
imagine the neural
guidance counselor,
and it says, you're a
great match for this.
But you don't test well
and things like that.
This could become, in
part, a partial substitute,
where you say, well,
I don't test well,
but I'll probably do
the actual thing well.
Because my brain
looks like the people
who do the actual thing well.
That's an interesting
possibility.
LUKE: And on behalf of Google,
I would like to thank Matt.
I would also like to say
UCLA's very lucky to have you,
and we are very lucky to
have you for this hour.
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN:
Thank you, Luke.
LUKE: Thank you so much.
MATTHEW LIEBERMAN: All right.
LUKE: Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]